[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and of
course i got chuck nice with me check
hey neil
guess what we're gonna talk about today
okay dead people my favorite
my favorite
we're talking about forensic pathology
today
and we've got two very special guests to
help us deliver that content and this
first a friend of star talk patricia
cornwell she's been a guest before uh
and last time we had her on as a guest
we talked about
crime and space and she has a a couple
of novels that take us there and her
latest novel is called autopsy so
uh she's she's into this it's the
continuation of her case scarpetta
series
she is
a medical examiner in her crime novels
so it's fun to follow the same character
thread throughout a series of novels it
feels like you get to know the character
and you anticipate future writings but
to help us in this we went deep into
the medical examiner's office here in
new york city and came up with dr
jonathan hayes
dr hayes welcome to star talk
thanks uh neil thanks chuck yeah
now so you you came to to the writing
profession
having started as a sort of professional
of dead people what what what what is
your official sort of title other than
sort of
you work in the medical examiner's
office but what does someone call you
as a profession as a scientific
profession
my scientific title is i'm a forensic
pathologist and you know pathologist is
a physician who makes diagnosis by
examining samples taken from patients
and that may be a blood sample or if you
have a weird mold you'll biopsy
is also the physicians who do autopsies
an autopsy is an examination of the body
after death and it's carried out in
order to get as much information as
possible about the cause and the
circumstances of that death it starts by
looking at the outside of the body
body's examined for scars or tattoos or
identifying marks and the evidence of
disease or injury and the body is opened
and examined internally we'll examine
all the organs
we'll place the remains of the organs
back in the body and we may do some
additional testing for example looking
for drugs or we do some dna testing
uh if there are any injuries internally
we'll document those too and then we'll
perform uh we'll prepare an autopsy
report so that that's basically what a
pathologist does now i'm a forensic
pathologist and that's a sub-specialty
of pathology and forensic pathologists
do autopsies on the victims of violent
unnatural suspicious deaths so on a
daily basis uh i examine wounds and i
interpret so if you get shot or stabbed
when you get to the er the er docs are
going to just be examining you to try
and try and save your life they're not
going to interpret the wounds they may
have guesses at what's an entrance with
what's an accident but that's the area
of expertise of the pathologist the
forensic pathologist and so on a daily
basis i'm looking at wounds and trying
to interpret those wounds and what
actually happened to the person now how
often doctor
uh do you
examine someone
who has been felled by gunshot
and your uh your determination is oh
they didn't die of a gunshot wound
actually gunshot wounds are uh far more
likely to be lethal than most other
types of injury if for example they're
five to five times more likely to be
to die if you're shocked than if you're
stabbed
wow
ah
okay but so that that that brings to
that puts on the table the very question
if let's say it's not a gunshot wound
with where you have that sort of the
easy statistics on that if two people
just sort of got into a fight and then
one person ultimately dies
is is it
important that you find out the actual
thing that killed the person
or
or does that even matter if the person's
dead and they have multiple injuries
that sort of lead up no it's it's
it's critically important that we find
out exactly why the person is dead
that's our haze on death you know we
have to know exactly why the person died
because you would be surprised at the
complexities of the questions that arise
the legal questions and the medical
questions when someone dies particularly
in an altercation or a fight
so we spend a lot of time getting it
right and we have endless debates about
the exact wording of the death
certificate
wow and are is what you do filmed
no it's it's we document our findings
photographically i mean occasionally
you'll find the video documentation of a
crime scene there'll be a video walk
through
um but what the the autopsy itself is
not
why not
because i i really do i don't know it's
just tradition
tradition
i'm sure there'd be a lot of extraneous
information an autopsy can be long for
example a typical autopsy say you have a
40 year old man who's jogging on a
treadmill it is uh at his gym and
collapses that autopsies you know he's
got something straightforward like heart
disease which is the most likely cause
of death there that autopsy will take
about an hour but if you have a complex
case like a a a child abuse case a fatal
child abuse case those can take a couple
of days
um so it's a long period of time also i
i don't i i don't think anyone likes to
be you know closely monitored while
they're doing you know their work
here's why i ask i mean presumably
forensic pathology has come a long way
over the decades there might be things
in 10 years someone would know to look
for that you don't yet know to look for
because the field has not advanced to
that point wouldn't it be good if we
could reopen the videos and have a third
party do with the autopsy based on the
video as though they were your eyes
looking at the same uh body
i i understand what you're saying but
the thing is
i when you say that you know forensic
polly has come a long way it really
hasn't i mean
this is a stab wound in 2021 looks like
a stab wound in 1921 or a stab wound in
1821
um and we do document things very
thoroughly we take a lot of photographs
uh i mean i suppose you could put on
some virtual reality headset and video
record and have some three-dimensional
interactive thing going on there
um but i don't i don't think that sort
of
well
you know perhaps obviously
you're now talking about unknown
unknowns so i don't really know the
answer to that question but i think it
would be terribly cumbersome to try and
have a video camera
documenting every single step of the
order so so is what you're saying that
for what you do
it it really is the fact that we
continue to kill each other kind of the
same way
we don't we don't really get that
creative when it comes to killing each
other
well he'd be so you'd be surprised i
mean one of the things i've been doing
this work for over 30 years now and
every week i see something i've never
seen before
and
it's not so much in terms of the
homicides it's not so much the murders
you know murder is murder people have
knives and guns and baseball bats and
whatnot it's it's more just the peculiar
circumstance the particular things that
people get you know positions that
people get themselves into there'll
always be something at a death scene
that you can't explain
that that's fascinating actually no now
i i don't know that you can major in
forensic pathology in college so what
what does one major in is it pre-med
what what are some of the kings that get
to where you are
it's to become a forensic pathologist
you go to college you do pre-med you go
to medical school then after graduating
medical school you do three years of
at least three years three to five years
of pathology residency then you do a
one-year forensic training uh which i
did in miami wow and uh and then all of
a sudden 12 years after you began you're
a forensic pathologist now i work in a
medical examiner's system a medical
examiner is a physician who's
specialized in uh forensic pathology uh
it's not in an elected position uh and
we investigate deaths violent and
natural and suspicious deaths for the
city or jurisdiction yeah you're quincy
i've actually never watched that [ __ ] oh
man i used to watch that show when i was
a kid man quincy was the best jack
klugman man
he used to walk around he had he he
would eat sandwiches
he would eat sandwiches during the
during the autopsy the guy was great man
i i enjoy a good sandwich but you know
no one eats in the autumn serum it's not
sort of place you sit down and go this
is an appetizing place to enjoy
[Laughter]
so what of this training and your life
experience did you feel compelled to put
into your novel
do i have precious blood
a hard precious
precious blood was the first one and a
heart death was the second and the first
the first is is like i think in most
novelists it's a very uh you know
semi-autobiographical i should say it's
set in in new york city after 9 11. it's
a serial killer story um but i used a
lot of my day-to-day experiences i don't
i i can't we don't really talk about our
cases and it's a matter of medical
privacy but i wanted to talk about the
things i've seen and the things that
disturbed and upset me so i put a lot of
that into the entered into the book and
911 was one of the things that disturbed
it and
certainly my work after that i worked in
this office for you know for eight solid
months which was trying to identify
people that was that was the hardest
part of my life i think absolutely but i
tried to make i i tried to make the uh
the uh description of
you know what forensics is and what it
feels like to be an immoral and the
smell and the sights of death i tried to
make them realistic
so jonathan if i make it personal uh
based on what you just said how do you
not give up on mankind how do you stay
positive about anything
well the last few years have been have
made it pretty hard to stay positive
about anything but
i think you know it's been my experience
that human beings do do terrible things
to each other but also
for the most part when given the
opportunity people do the right thing
and i i recognize that the murders i see
they're the exceptions and though there
may be horrible crimes indeed
on a on a daily basis most people are
trying to do the right thing
okay
okay okay um all right as a comedian i
will say that um
good for you because
like i don't deal with anything you deal
with and i think people are awful period
but
i'm inspired by you man
yeah it is inspiring it's it's it's hope
prevails i think is how we think about
that
so um what's interesting if we contrast
jonathan your
your pathway into writing novels with
that of patricia um cornwall who
is
uh shared with us some of
what inspires her when she approaches a
novel
that needs a bit of forensic pathology
to make it run let's check it out what
we're really talking about is
exploration we're exploring which is
exactly why we want to go to the moon
and do all those cool things is and when
if you're going to be an artist you need
to explore
and go out and let it tell you what the
story is let it tell you what the
painting is like you know james mcneil
whistler he had had this boat when he
would take him out in this flat bottom
boat and the thames at dusk and he would
look he'd stand there on the filthy
thames in the victorian era and look at
what the light was doing he'd remember
that and then he would go back and he
would paint something evocative because
he was there
and you feel he was there you feel
hemingway was in the places that he's
talking about and i very much encourage
to people here's my i have three words
for everybody just show up
never know what you might find
so that i so i like that because what
what you're saying is that to really not
to put words in your mouth but to infuse
a story with a certain authenticity it
can't be just things you've read about
or heard about if you experience them
firsthand they manifest differently even
in your sentences and in the words you
choose and and and and your emotional
investment becomes that much deeper is
that a fair accounting of what you just
told me that's absolutely right um you
want to invoke your senses uh i mean why
go into a morgue if you can just see a
video of an autopsy
um
because
when your senses are assaulted by
everything in there it is a totally
different thing it's as different as
reality from virtual reality probably
even more so and for example i can
remember i can remember how shocked i
would feel when i would go down there to
scribe for the medical examiners and i
would put on the gloves and you know
this was back in the day we didn't get
in spacesuits like they do today with
hazmat and all that
and i would put my hands on the body on
the table or i'd lean on it while i'm
jotting down whatever they're telling me
and i'd it's like as cold as marble
because and you would be
amazed over and over again about things
that
that you would not have emotional
reactions to it if you didn't feel it
and you weren't there um or you didn't
see it or you weren't you weren't
standing there when the state trooper
is looking through the woman's wallet
and she was hit by a car on her way home
from the bar about three o'clock in the
morning
and you know nobody really knew what
she'd gone there for or why and she was
by herself such a bad hour and he's
going through a wallet and he finds a
little fortune from a fortune cookie
that she had saved and it said you will
still you will soon have an encounter
that will change the course of your life
so she's going off to a bar to meet her
encounter not thinking it's going to be
a car and you look at these things and
you don't know whether to laugh or to
cry
but you do know
i i feel this if if i don't go and see
those things i have no right to write
about them so jonathan you you probably
feel the same way right because your
your writing emanates from your
first-hand experiences good good and bad
yeah i think that in terms of
the sensual aspects the smells the
sounds the sights yeah there's no
substitute for first-hand experience
then again i mean
look at speculative fiction in science
fiction people use their imaginations
and think what would it be like to see
this or to experience that and i think
that's really rich too in some ways
knowing what the truth is uh kind of at
some level deadens the fantasy you know
i i don't take any in my own writing i
don't take any liberties with the
science because i can't i wouldn't i
wouldn't lie about it and that limits
what you can do uh with with the set of
facts in front of you and so i that's
one of the reasons i really enjoy a show
like csi uh where which was as i said
before it's not so much um forensic
science it's forensic science fiction i
think they they they take the principles
of forensic science and they make it
more glamorous and they speed it up they
put sexy lighting on it and the end
result i think it may not get the
technical accuracy
of the forensic science but it gets the
romance of the science and i really do
like that and it's for that reason i
think csi has been great because it's
attracted a lot of people into forensics
and this is a field that really needs
good people but smart young people so
what you're what you're saying is you
um when you're exploring the fiction of
your storytelling it's in the whatever
relationships led to the crime um you're
not in a position to sort of stretch
uh any other uh
science i say that only because we look
at a stephen king novel often he touches
on supernatural forces and it leaves
them a little bit cloaked but something
manifests and that adds another
dimension that people seem to like to
watch and even read about but but you're
sticking to the facts on this one
well that's that's just my writing i
wouldn't rule out writing you know
fantasy or horror novel or something
like that but even if i do if like the
well cut someone's throats i want to
make you know to accurately depict the
spray of blood or or what have you
and so when i watch when i watch a lot
of like crime stuff
sometimes it's at a procedural level
like the cops wouldn't do that i
wouldn't say that and then sometimes
it's just no that looks completely wrong
for example when the most when i'm
watching a horror movie or
a crime movie and and like they visit a
crime scene three days later although
all the blood is still bright red that's
upsetting to me because blood goes brown
and then it goes black right and it just
it just looks so fake right but but but
i i mean i i understand i mean since
i've written you know fiction myself i
understand the challenges of creating
something interesting and riveting and i
understand people taking liberties with
the facts i don't think
patty cornwall does that um because she
she too knows what it's like so guys
i've got to take a quick break when we
come back we're going to find out how
patricia ends up putting her crime in
space
apparently earth wasn't good enough
let's let's put people in space and have
them commit crimes there where you then
need some more forensic pathology to
figure out what the hell is going on
when star talk returns
we're back star talk
we're talking about forensic pathology
with best-selling author patricia
cornwell
and we have an authentic medical
examiner in the house
in the house we've got dr jonathan dr
jonathan hayes who's not only medical
examiner for new york city of all places
but also a novelist in his own right
chuck right before the end of the second
segment look like you want to slip into
question what was that well because he
talked about how um
when you write forensic science fiction
that it makes it kind of sexy and it
draws people into the field uh which is
great so did you say sexy said romantic
this day well um you know i think i
think sexy is right too yeah you know
i'm sorry my name's not sexy
unfortunately
unfortunately unfortunately for me my
romance leads to sexy
but what i'm interested to know is do
you find the same thing in your field of
astrophysics do you think science
fiction causes people to now
like pursue
the science of the cosmos
yeah it does i so that's why even though
just like jonathan i'll call out things
that are not real or wouldn't have
happened that way but i say the overall
impact is positive that
because what people can do now is they
can get interested and then they say i
i'm i like that
let me read some more about it and then
the reading some more about it actually
brings them into an anchored state of
understanding whereas the fantasy sort
of tickled their interest uh up front
and jonathan i heard
anecdotally
that biology and chemistry professors in
college found an increase in women
taking
courses that were sort of pre-forensic
inspired by
the actors who you like you want to be
like them in the series uh crime scene
investigation in csi did you find this
as well coming up
well i think that uh increasingly uh
forensics is becoming a matriarchy there
are a lot of a lot of women going into
the field and certainly in my field
my office i would estimate is probably
more than 50 female when it comes to the
medical exam and stuff and i think
that's common in in in other areas too
but i don't think it's just that they're
impressed by the the actors
i i think they have you know
minds that are interested in problem
solving and
figuring out how to bury a body
no but i mean i i grew up at a time when
no scientist was portrayed as anything
you'd want to be
like if you were cool and you saw a
movie that had scientists in it the
scientists were not cool and so there
was no
there was no draw there was no pop
culture force operating on how you might
align your life's ambitions and csi all
the actors are beautiful um the men the
women the storytelling what they're
wearing plus they're shown with real
life problems right they're boyfriends
girlfriends relationship problems so
they're fully fleshed out characters so
jonathan are you a fully fleshed out
i did god that's a difficult question to
ask
how does that work at the bar
someone said hey what do you do i study
dead bodies it's like that's a that's a
short conversation it might seem to me
no people you know because there is this
interest there was an article in new
york magazine a few years back that said
that forensic pathologists are the new
supermodels because i mean you turn on
your tv set any hour of the day or night
you're going to see a forensic show
where it's like you know true crime or
whether it's some sort of thriller
whether there's someone's burying a body
in the basement or whatnot but the way
my career in forensics in general is
portrayed in popular culture really
catches the imagination of people and i
think it's because at some level in the
old days a hero was a guy with muscles
he knew how to handle a gun uh and
forensics is an area where a nerd with a
brain and some sharp insights is able to
be even more powerful than that and
that's why the forensic science they
think become it makes forensic scientist
becomes a good hero well so let's uh
let's pick up with my interview with
patricia cornwell in her next book
there's like crime
in space let's see what she says about
that i think that i might be the first
author that has written about a a a case
of violence
in um low earth orbit in microgravity in
space in other words um to do it in the
credible way that that it's not science
fiction i mean everything that i have in
that scene that scarpetta has to
remotely work from the situation room in
the white house to get i mean it's all
within the realm of possibility and the
physics of it um what would happen when
there's blood or the type of projectile
somebody might use if you were going to
do that and look you know as well as i
do the russians have carried guns up
there to the space station they don't
you know nasa doesn't advertise that but
it's true
um and we it's the the whole point is my
little mantra these days is from from
earth from space to ground to six feet
under because wherever we go we will
export what we do whether it's in
orbiting laboratories down the road or
when people actually go to the moon and
try to set up habitats or mars or
it's going to happen and we're also
going to have
death you know we're going to have
things um that we don't like to think
about and for me
i'm always wondering what are you going
to do about that
people will be people whether they're on
earth or in space and you're there to
tell that that kind of story well you
know the thing that's kind of fun about
it because i talked to the real people i
talked to nasa people about this you
know i talked to to jack fisher that you
know astronaut who was up there for a
while we talked about what blood would
do and fluids and just to be clear blood
that's not in your body
that's true blood that's not in your
body blood that has spilled out of your
body what will it get and then what
happens you know if
where you've got a scene where something
like this has occurred and some
astronauts
you know come and will use the dream
chaser i know it's not crude yet but it
probably will be um and they you know
they get to this this orbiter that's in
peril well if you've had
anything where you have death inside and
a violent death what's that going to be
like and how does a medical examiner
work out this brings up an interesting
question you are completely trained for
earth-based crimes that is a crimes
operating under sort of the laws of
physics as they manifest in 1g here on
earth can you imagine a future where
if we have colonies on the moon or mars
or beyond or or hotels in space
can you imagine a branch a sub-branch of
your field that then has to sort of
learn space physics to do your job
well you know
you know i don't know how much space
physics is going to be involved i think
the periods of time that man is going to
spend in zero gravity you're going to be
fairly limited and perhaps not in when
it comes to things like space station
but when you're looking at actually
larger colonies
where people would actually live which
is where i think
violence is mostly like likely to play
out i think they'll be at normal gravity
and you know the traditional medical
examiner role is going to be pretty much
the same i think it'll be fairly
specialized the cases like like patty
was talking about like a i'm assuming
some sort of violent blood spilling
murder takes place in in microgravity or
zero gravity and i don't know if that's
going to be frequent enough for currents
that it's going to develop into its own
full-fledged specialty but it's going to
hold not yeah
but that that will be that will be a
challenge i mean it'll be interesting
and when i was thinking about that too
or what it could mean a crime scene in
zero gravity the first thing that struck
me was what the patty was talking about
was the um
blood blood drop that uh splatter
dynamics going to be different
because you know you've probably seen
your you know when you walk along after
you've cut yourself you can see that the
shape of the blood spatter uh on your
floor or whatever you can interpret the
way you're moving and or if you're
standing still if you're standing still
a person is standing still and dripping
blood from say a weapon onto the floor
it tends to have a round appearance
whereas when you're moving it has to
have a teardrop appearance but that's
going to be different in in microgravity
or zero gravity and so i think there's
going to be some interesting science
that's probably going to evolve because
of that but i have to say i mean this is
probably a question for you just how
realistic are these we talk about uh you
know uh colonizing distant planets but
on a large scale how realistic is it i
mean we had the concord in what 1965 or
something like that we had supersonic
travel available to to
again the very wealthy man um but it's
gone now and so how realistic are these
streams of colonizing uh fall planets
yeah i think if i i'm i'm tend to be a
little on the the skeptical side that
any of that is going to happen anytime
soon but that shouldn't prevent people
from getting ready for it either legally
or medically
or or the like
little things for example as i
understand it from movies i've seen if
you die while you're seated then blood
collects in your butt and in your feet
or something right because there's you
don't have this sort of action
this vascular action to keep blood
circulating and if you're in zero g the
blood doesn't collect anywhere so a lot
of your cues you would use to judge how
long a body's been dead are not
available to you right yeah it's a
fascinating thought you're absolutely
right
and how quickly will people bleed from
an open mood because zero gravity yeah
i was just going to ask from a forensic
standpoint because one of the things
that happens in space is like a common
death is like suit malfunction or
something and the person freezes
solid because they're in space
now could would you be able to do an
autopsy on like if if the person died
would you be able to do an autopsy on a
solidly frozen
you
body
it's it's it's it's like you know when
you have a frozen body it's like trying
to chip into an iceberg
you're not going to get very far so what
you have to do is throw the body and of
course as you for the body the body
begins to break down fairly rapidly of
course in space i think there may also
be issues of
of desiccation the body drying out very
quickly right and there are questions of
barret trauma um and neil knows far more
about this than i do where where the
body is subjected to tremendous
pressures out in the vacuum of space or
when
when we do start to see it it'll be
interesting but
you know i think i may have retired
before that happens
i want to return relevant
i have to ask you know how often am i
hanging out with a with a forensic
pathologist could you explain exactly
what rigor mortis is
rigor mortis is stiffening of the
muscles that occurs after death the uh
the the muscle proteins gradually kind
of coagulate and as they coagulate this
they stiffen up the muscles stiffen and
you first detect it in well the first
place you can detect it is with goose
flesh because uh you you have tiny
little muscles that raise and lower the
hairs and on your body to trap air and
keep you warm or not so in the early
stages when rigger first comes in uh
you'll start to see a little bit of
goose flesh developing and you see these
tiny little bits just to be clear
you're on a first name basis with rigor
mortis okay you call it rigger
yeah
yeah rigging waters it's a bit long
yeah yeah
i'm not on a first name basis i'm sorry
maybe i'll warm up to that but
you never get there
but
then then you you test for rigor by
trying to bend joints and
fairly small joints like finger joints
become stiff first because it takes a
lot of muscles to to stiffen the hip
joint or the knee joint so contest in
the fingers first then we tested the jaw
and then the the arms etc and so from
the from the amount of rigor that's
present in the body you can get some
soft sense of how long the person has
been dead to get that degree of
stiffness
now if someone a lot of it relates to
the body temperature at the time of
death if someone has a seizure at the
time they die if they have violence you
should say they're doing cocaine or
something like that they have a seizure
and they die uh that will raise the body
temperature and the person will go into
rigor mortis faster so you have to be
very careful interpreting the time since
death is one of the hardest things we do
it's part of the the science that's
closest to an art really
wait and so so then i heard that riga
mortis eventually goes away so what
happens there oh it does the the muscle
proteins begin to break down again and
and the rigor sort of slackens
but now you're starting to get onto
onto you know the body's beginning is
about to begin to break down typically
you can feel rigor mortis by about six
hours after death
it's generally there by about 12 hours
and it goes off by about 36 hours oh wow
wow okay so that'll that whole
expression where someone you refer to a
dead body as a stiff that's a temporary
condition yeah
yeah but i think stiff sounds better
than temporarily stiff we
we don't use that expression
you'd actually be surprised we i mean
it's because we see death the whole time
we're not alarmed or surprised there's
not an intense emotional reaction to it
unless it's the death of a child or some
sort of particularly tragic
uh circumstance there so we we don't say
the word cadaver we don't say corpse we
just call them bodies
oh wow
yeah that's very politically correct of
you
correct i'm just gonna say jonathan i
don't i don't think they'll be offended
and and if they are who are they going
to tell
yeah
so how about this if uh just before we
go to break if a crime is committed in a
distant place again i'm thinking space
here because uh patricia's novel was in
space
if some crime happens in space are you
able to talk someone through
an investigation of a scene if let's say
they're just generally scientifically
illiterate but they have no medical
background such as what you have
can you talk them through it and then
have them submit a report on your behalf
for having done so
i think i i mean i think i could i could
tell them what to look for i could tell
them how to turn the body and and what
to check for
um i think i could do that i mean
obviously i'd like to document it as far
as they could whether you know with
photographs or videos so i could see for
myself yeah exactly so you could do this
from the beach while they're up there
doing
the in theory in theory but there's no
real substitute for seeing with your own
eyes and that's actually what her toxin
is autopsy in his own eyes and says
having your own eyes looking at the body
and seeing what's going on
about that what is the temperature of
the
re of the the slidy things that you put
the body and down in the morgue
we don't use those anymore
i'm sorry come on no no no bring them
back we need them i'm sorry the old
superstitions have to be disposed of no
i mean it's like it's like at any you
couldn't clean the floors of those
refrigerators you know because of that
because of the you know slide in and out
things so eventually they begin to reek
and uh and build up fluid so it's a
horrible thing
it's just walk-in refrigerators like you
have a new local restaurant and a system
of gurneys for transporting the bodies
on
the only time we see those drawers meat
locker yeah
meat locker that's exactly what he said
i hope to god it's not like my local
restaurant
yeah we got a slab of steer right here
and we got ernie yeah ernie didn't make
it through last night
we're gonna take a quick break but more
on forensic pathology with our two
guests patricia cornwell and jonathan
hayes when star talk returns
we're back with jonathan hayes medical
examiner of new york city jonathan what
right before we took a break you were
about to tell a story because we were
talking about meat lockers
because we think
well no we we do
modern modern storage of bodies is in
walk-in coolers which are just very
efficient way to handle the space and
they're easy to clean um but uh you know
in terms of
meat blockers
during the cocaine wars of the 1980s and
until about 1990 in miami there were so
many homicides that they weren't able to
hold all the bodies in
in the more refrigerators and so what
they were forced to do was to rent
trucks and they rented some refrigerator
trucks and some of them had the burger
king logo on the outside of those
when word got out the bodies were being
stored in burger king refrigerator
trailers
apparently there was such an outcry
amongst the population uh that uh these
the agency got a large amount of money
to build this beautiful new
state-of-the-art facility with
appropriate body storage and so that's a
really upside of that
yeah actually
hold the pickle hold the lettuce and the
dead guy thanks
well i think these medical examiner's
offices really only sort of rapidly
improve when there's been a scandal i
mean it's one of the sad truths they
tend to be fairly neglected politically
no one wants to talk about them no one
wants to fund them so we tend to jump
forward when there's something terrible
like that happens
well so i have to ask in these meat
lockers and in refrigerator trucks
how are the dead humans stored are they
on meat hooks like slabs of beef
no actually
no they're not from meatballs
i am so disappointed now
this has really been disillusioning for
you both i can see
look i'm sorry we interviewed you we'd
rather just imagine this stuff don't
ruin it all with facts
that's that's what i was saying my old
boss talked to charles said she said
have an expression to slay an ugly
theory with a beautiful fact i'm sorry
the other way around yeah to slay a
beautiful theory with an ugly fact right
i'm sorry to make this such a sad thing
i mean no more bodies hanging on meat
hooks in
in refrigerators but you have to at
least store them horizontally right
otherwise it won't work
yeah well i mean i suppose you could
just store them vertically but the blood
would cool as you were talking about
earlier yeah no
the body is stored in a shelving system
it's all very modular and very efficient
there are all sorts of systems for mass
storage of bodies and
you know all agencies are prepared for
mass fatality events wow
so can i ask you this uh
a long time ago i interviewed a police
officer and he talked about a person who
was murdered and they found him in his
apartment in new york city the way they
found him is he leaked through the
ceiling
so
what would that be
what would your question chuck yeah my
question is
what happened if that's the case or was
this guy messing with me
no i'm sure he was telling you the truth
what happens is after death and the body
begins to break down there's no immune
system anymore the white cells die off
the bacteria now rage throughout the
body and the bacteria produce gas they
cause the body to bloat and they break
down the blood and cause it to go red
and green and create a lot of
discoloration and as the pressure in the
tissues builds from the the gas as the
body swells the body will exude fluids
as as its tissues break down that fluid
we call purge fluid and that will spill
out around the body and sometimes it'll
throw soak through the ceiling
holy crap
it's not an attractive thing yeah that's
uh that's terrible oh my goodness so so
the so the the bloating that makes the
body much less dense than it once was
because it's the same mass now occupying
a bigger volume this would then cause
the body to float
if it was dead and at the bottom of any
uh any
in the river so that's why you need
cement boots right
that's exactly why you need cement boots
but it's also why uh if someone goes
into the water into the eastern river
into the hudson uh during the winter it
may be a few months before the body
develops enough gas from bacterial
overgrowth that it'll actually start to
float up to the top so there may be
delay between someone drowning and us
actually finding the bodies there's a
popular notion that when spring comes
and the weather
warms up and the water temperature warms
up then you get a crop of a harvest of
bodies bobbing up to the surface it's
not quite that extreme but yeah we don't
bodies that are floating tend to
imputerify sometimes they you know they
get clothing
traps and air or they may have swallowed
some air and they can float because of
that but usually it's unfortunate
because they're beginning to break down
okay so just to be very precise this
because you're you're breaking down this
whole uh the whole evolution of a dead
body so
so the rigor mortis that gives us the
language where's the stiff right so we
got that then you bloat and then that
makes you buoyant so that gets us the
cement boots
part of crime right and
okay i'm just i'm just fleshing out the
full picture here so
this is highly illuminating for me
thank you no i mean taylor you're on top
of this stuff all right should have gone
into forensic medicine rather than
astrophysics
could abuse people like you
so oh dovetailing on what neil just said
could you
commit the perfect murder
you mean in terms of killing someone
getting away with it yes yes
leaving behind no evidence or no
discernible cause of death or
no way i mean forget alibis and all that
kind of police work stuff just like they
would never be able to trace it back to
you so we put jonathan together
with the tv series uh how to how to get
away with murder yeah there it is so the
two of them because they know what
everybody's looking for right yeah so
jonathan i better never see you having
lunch with viola davis
they're plotting
somebody's going
somebody's going down
childhood davis the star
of how to get away with murder so
wouldn't that make you a prime suspect
in a murder where there's otherwise no
evidence
good answer you should just stop there
don't say anything
i think i think it is possible it would
be possible to kill someone without
leaving any any clues or trace but uh
let's not go into that okay all right
but it is true
it is true it's very hard to dispose of
a dead body that's the big problem it's
not killing people it's getting getting
rid of the body we had a case where a
man murdered his wife and then he buried
her in the basement
and then for the next couple of weeks he
sat there watching endless repeats of
csi and then finally he went to the
police station says look you're going to
get me sooner or later i'm going to tell
you i murdered my wife and i buried her
in the basement wow
that's yeah so csi solved the crime
did well csi also creates problems
because now uh you know for a while at
least when the show was you know on the
air all the time and everyone loved it
there's six different variations i think
the cbs is actually bringing it back but
the juries began to demand higher levels
of visual proof they wanted more sort of
glamorous you know you know animations
and like incredible cutting-edge science
which as i said was on the border of
science fiction at that time right right
that was awesome by the way csi wasn't
just medical there was also some physics
involved in thermodynamics i mean not in
every episode but they would bring in
you know the some of the physical
sciences when they related to the crime
and the murder so that uh there were
some scientifically literate people
there i don't know if either of you know
csi had a traveling museum exhibit
where you would then solve your own
crime kids a kid exhibit where you go
step by step and they give you clues and
you have to figure it out so it was a
big force on the television landscape so
i was very impressed
to watch that unfold well how about the
future of uh a.i
ai is going to touch all of us in every
way
it already has in some professions
patricia thought about that
and she was very impressed with what the
future of ai might bring so let's find
out what she tells us what's happening
today
is is so amazing and the line between
what's real and what isn't
assuming we even know the difference
between the two the line is getting
blurrier and blurrier and so basically
when you think of an alexa or these
devices that we have
ultimately
everybody is you're going to have
artificial intelligence assistance
even if even if you don't know you've
got it and and that's the thing that's
both good and bad about it
is that it we can't be without it i mean
we can't we can't manage this world in
my opinion without artificial
intelligence especially uh think of air
traffic control when you have drones
buzzing around and things like that oh
wait wait wait you just said something
very important you're suggesting
that the complexity of the world we are
building for ourselves may one day
require ai just to navigate it well look
at what's happened with with your mobile
phones i mean we've created uh many
computers that people really almost
can't function without so jonathan is
there can you picture a day where ai
conducts the investigation and not you
i think this assistant would be would be
closer i i don't think uh ai will ever
be
you know who knows a thousand years
but for example things like an autopsy
not all bodies are the same everybody
has numerous different idiosyncrasies
they're very subtle little anatomic
differences in structure
and actually examining the the body is a
very complex thing it's visually like
sometimes olfactory and then it's you
know the touch and you know the feeling
of you know actually putting your hands
in and examining the length of the wound
etc i think it'll be a long time before
there's uh
you know robots or whatever that are
sensitive enough to be able to do that
with the discrimination a human can do
that said when they do i expect they may
have a slightly higher degree of
accuracy i think there's less room for
observer bias then but for a long time
those robots will have to be overseen
by you know someone human to see if
they're if they haven't gone hopelessly
off the rails i think where ai will be
useful
in things like in a crime scene that
there is a thousand there's a million
things going on in the crime scene i
think the big problem is trying to
decide what's relevant to the crime and
what's more for example if you have a
dead body lying on the floor there's
blood spat all over the place there
could be a thousand
blood spotted droplets distributed about
the floor on the walls even the ceiling
of the apartment sometimes
and if you think at some point the
killer stood with his knife over the
victim or was carrying the knife and and
may have left his own blood on
on the scene how do you figure out which
of all those drops of blood is
significant and which is which relates
to the killer is not actually the
victim's blood
and i think with pattern recognition
and uh you know that's the sort of thing
that i think that ai down the road might
be able to look at a
like a dense information field look for
patterns and find out the subtle
exception that would escape the human
eye
but i do think it's a long time i and i
you know i do think a long time before
we'll be able to rely on ai
for example at the moment there's a lot
of discussion in forensic pathology
about stopping doing autopsies and just
doing it all virtual a vertopsy is an
examination of the body using a t s a ct
scanner and the the swiss are very keen
on this and they feel that it can
completely replace doing the autopsy
itself they don't they still do
autopsies uh but i think increasing
they're moving towards virtual autopsies
the thing is in in in new york in the
legal system new york lawyers are not
going to say you know i'm not going to
just sit back and accept that the uh the
uh
virtual the ct scan is accurate that is
that it's a subdued hematoma rather than
say meningitis that you're looking at so
i think there's going to be it's going
to be a while before that sort of
technology comes in and plays a
specifically a guiding or controlling
part i don't know if that'll ever happen
but but we'll see
you sound like chuck because i said this
chuck you said no comedy is too
complicated for ai to take it over
absolutely
chuck just wants to make sure he's still
employed
there's no way there's no way they could
tell a joke uh not not not with all the
nuance that a comedian does that's and
by the way if they ever do you can rest
assure a glass of water inside their
circuitry is waiting
coming right from me
that's called murder chuck
yes
but it's the kind of murder that's
outside oh there's a word for it aside
oh
a word i don't know if you can kill
something that's inanimate but that's a
philosophical discussion for another
form of writing
but i think you're right i think that
gets it because if someone can you
imagine a robot comedian trying to
handle a heckler you know the
complexities involved in that the
analysis of what was being said which
will have probably obscure cultural
references if you're a silicon based
machine and then actually trying to how
to formulate a response but it's a
really good example i think even just
you know the touring test if the
computer to pass the turing test is
still well that's a lot less challenging
than it was before right it reminds me
there's a brief moment in the movie
terminator where he's he's repairing his
injured arm in a hotel room
and
the someone knocks on the door
and he has to figure out what response
to give him so you see this
you see through his mind's eye i mean
through his computer eye you see a
multiple
choice it's um go away i'm busy or come
back later or [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
chooses that response so it could be if
you if you have a a a ai comedian and
there's a heckler they can decide
whether they're nice to the heckler
right or not it's just a it's a it's a
knob that you turn right but jonathan
you said something very important which
i i'm very sensitive to just in my own
field where pattern recognition humans
are good at it but we can be very biased
if you take an unbiased
pattern recognizing
ai
it can for complex things just like you
said that the splatter pattern of blood
or the a pattern of
of of
casing shell casings where they landed
and how
they might be able to do a back
extrapolation into where the gun was
when it was fired and
there could be some interesting sort of
three-dimensional analysis that ai could
perform that we couldn't so that i'm i'm
impressed
by that path that it could take that you
would suggested
absolutely that's how i think it'll
unroll i mean when i first started when
i first came to new york and it was
1990 we had this nightmarish homicide
rate we're having six murders a day and
they just had no time to investigate the
cases so we'd be working off for the
scene investigation i didn't go to the
scenes but we'd get that with the
investigating detectives would show up
with like six or seven polaroids at the
crime scene you know poor resolution not
ideally photographed not ideally lit
and it just wasn't great and then you
know fast forward you know whatever 30
years
and we've got you know video we've got
high resolution for even even the
photograph your your iphone takes is is
just amazing and we have this really
cool machine there that you you put it
in the center of the room and it just
scans the entire room very blade runner
machine scans the entire room and
measures all the distances and can
rebuild a model of that room and that's
fascinating technology and i think
that's where things are going i mean you
see it in the real estate market now you
know when people are selling the houses
they can have a virtual walkthrough
using this thing but you can measure
accurately down to the centimeter and i
think taking the information from that
and feeding it into the computer but you
know discriminating between what's real
and what is irrelevant is really um the
big problem in forensics and it's one of
the things that frustrates me in like
csi gil grissom will walk into the scene
and then he'll pick up a single fragment
of glass in a whole field filled with
glasses well this just doesn't fit this
is the problem and that is the answer
and it just doesn't work like that but
but if if that were sherlock watson the
a.i
sherlock watson
i would be able to do that
sherlock watson sherlock watson would
walk in and just be like this man's been
dead for 12 hours you're like no no he's
12 hours and 36 minutes right they were
like yeah but the rig rigger mortis
isn't right and he'd be like rigger
please no this man i can tell you has
been dead
sherlock watson the good one the ai
very good well i mean that's the
direction we're going in but i you know
you know how in you know how fallible
computers are
you know it's still they still depend on
i still think for a very long time and
they've forever they're going to need
humans to sign off on them but they
haven't gotten the stick wrong and of
course that reintroduces the whole
question of bias all over again just
yeah big challenges and forensics
of course
once again sherlock watson sends another
black man to jail
damn
damn
that means it's time to end
jonathan it's been great having you on
you're the first forensic pathologist
i've ever had a conversation with uh and
and maybe it showed for better or for
worse fascinating stuff but
have you been rude to the other forensic
pathologists or something
no i just haven't
it's just a non-overlapping venn
diagrams in my life but it was delighted
to join us in my interview with patricia
cornwell and delighted to hear that you
you have enough two novels out there
precious blood and a hard death
and i will look for them uh wherever
books are sold uh of course and so chuck
thanks for being here as always a
pleasure always yeah and jonathan i
think we're going to try to find you
again because this this this topic has
no end
good it doesn't and i was really
interested to hear your thoughts about
the future of space colonies because
that's something i think about a lot in
the last few months as we've watched the
private enterprises take people into
space and just here's a quick one for
you
so if you bury someone on the moon there
are no microorganisms there to decompose
the body so the only organisms are the
microbes that were in your body when you
were buried but there's nothing exterior
to that so the whole decomposition arc
will be very different because of that
because it's not really soil well that's
that's that's all you need though we
carry there's some sort of horrific
statistic about what percentage of our
body mass is bacteria and it's a
significant portion
i just looked at it we have more
bacterial cells in our body then we have
body cells
so that that that's pretty freaky right
i think the rate limiting thing there is
going to be cold and um is also going to
be uh water bacteria most bacteria like
a little bit of warmth and water to to
germinate jonathan delight to have you
on thanks for that good to meet you
it's a pleasure chuck chuck always good
to have you this has been star talk
forensic pathology edition
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]